welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and as marvel studios prepares for
a snowy new york christmas with hawkeye
fighting track-suited russians in
spider-man ghostbusting variant sinister
six villains new evidence has emerged
hinting at how both of these titles
could be coordinating to reveal papa
feige's secret plan to reveal in the mcu
faces from the netflix marvel world
vincent d'onofrio as kingpin wilson fisk
and charlie cox as daredevil matt
murdock are we looking at a christmas
miracle of wilson biscuits coming to
slamming your head in a car door
i am going to break down all the new
clues for kingpin's rumored appearance
in hawkeye as well as the possibility he
could be the mystery sixth villain of
spider-man no way home and lay out the
timeline of how many advent calendar
windows we gotta open before we get to
the fist-flavored chocolate it tastes
like blood ever since netflix canceled
daredevil and its other marvel titles
and those film and tv rights have
reverted to marvel fans have been
begging feige to formally canonize cox
and dinoprio in a marvel studios title
after rumors of cox being spotted on the
set of spider-man no way home the
trailer did show someone meeting with
peter parker when he was in custody whom
many speculated could have matched the
soft furry arms of charlie cox playing
matt murdock here peter's defense
attorney now i argued that it would be a
bit weird for someone defending peter to
slam those files so aggro-like and that
this guy's body type doesn't really
match charlie cox's indeed wincox was
asked about this by comicbook.com he
confirmed i can promise you
those are not my forearms and the same
day in the same press junket even cox
also said i wouldn't want to ruin
something either way like yeah do you
know what i mean like so
it makes me a little anxious in that
regard
you know because
so it's a difficult you know so it's
difficult thing to talk about you know
all i would say is like
i guess
everyone myself included is just going
to have to wait and see what happens
charlie cox what a guy just makes you
want to see him and then see you even
more and yes while you could totally
interpret these as a grateful actor just
trying to manage fan expectations while
not disappointing anyone it's also not
very hard to compare his denials to
andrew garfield's denials like his
recent appearance on jimmy fallon i
heard about it
and i did see it and it's a photoshop
it's just impossible to know what to
believe these days in the world of nerd
news but the case for kingpin just got
way more compelling with the hawkeye
trailer which gave us some actual
evidence pointing at his existence in
this world the series is confirmed to
adapt the 2012 matte fraction run of the
comics so evident of an influence that
the series logo was taken directly from
the cover page of that comic series
which you don't often see marvel studios
do this show will introduce the russian
gang of the tracksuit draculas a group
with ties to wilson disc and features an
auction scene speculated to be the
auction organized by madame mask in the
matt fraction run in which kingpin bids
on a tape of clint barton assassinating
a dictator in the case of the show in
the mcu it could be footage of barton
slaughtering members of that cartel in
mexico or the yakuza in tokyo something
this world hasn't yet publicly linked
with clint barton and therefore could be
what scares him into staying in new york
in order to stop kate bishop from
moonlighting as that ronin assassin
figure actually if you think about it
it's a similar dilemma peter parker now
finds himself in in no way home the
public now linking his face with war
crimes but in this case clinton barton
actually did the stuff i mean arguably
justified but you know enough to turn
black widow's stomach from finishing
that peanut butter sandwich there's also
the fact that this hawkeye series will
introduce maya lopez echo echo worked
for kingpin for a time in the comics and
her father was killed by kingpin and her
father has been cast in this series but
thanks to hellofresh for sponsoring this
video get mouth-watering seasonal
recipes and fresh pre-measured
ingredients delivered right to your door
with hellofresh america's number one
meal kit hello fresh makes cooking at
home fun easy and affordable i like
cooking but i don't have a ton of extra
time to plan or prep i love how hello
fresh helps you save time and stress you
can get some tasty home-cooked food on
the table in just 20 minutes with their
quick and easy options fall is here and
things are getting busier make
hellofresh part of your back-to-school
routine they offer a wide variety of
quick meal options like 20-minute
dinners or oven-ready pizzas it's
flexible to fit your lifestyle easily
change your delivery days or food
preferences and skip a week whenever you
need and is a nice little nod to our
friend the planet the packaging
hellofresh uses to ship your food is
almost entirely made of recyclable or
recycled content i just made a hello
fresh recipe of a parmesan pork loaf
with an amazing red sauce like this is
the red sauce i'm gonna use for all my
recipes now even non-italian ones i
loved it that much and i felt like a
professional line cook i might have to
quit making youtube videos so i can get
into cooking i'm just kidding i'm just
kidding bing order up their meals are
just really delicious with more
five-star rated recipes than any other
meal kit service go to hellofresh.com
and use the code rockstars14 to get 14
free meals plus free shipping that's
code rockstars 14 at hellofresh.com to
get 14 free meals plus free shipping
maybe we can find some answers on
twitter yup you thought we forgot but
nope it's time for a tweet down
over the summer some redditers claimed
that dinafria would be appearing in
hawkeye and when people tweeted donafroe
asking him about it he liked those
tweets and then this week when the
hawkeye trailer dropped on monday
minutes later dinofrio tweeted a poem
about a three-legged dog which when
commenters asked if that dog was lucky
the pizza dog or if this meant kingpin
would return in the show or asking about
the suspicious timing of this tweet
d'onofrio liked those replies too now i
don't know if that means anything
celebrities tweet random crap all the
time and often just like the replies
without thinking into rio did later
tweet that people might have been
reading too much into things and that he
just loved playing fisk on daredevil
really i'm more curious about the timing
of all this folks spiderman no way home
will release right between hawkeye
episode 4 and episode 5. now at first i
didn't know how much to read into that
because i assumed hawkeye was going to
take place on the first christmas after
the blip december 2023 which would be a
year before no way home just based on
lila barton saying this is our first
christmas together in years but
a set photo shows a sign that reads
happy new year 2025 meaning this must be
december 2024 so either clint just like
blew off his family for christmas 2023
or lila is full of crap but either way
this confirms it hawkeye is actually
going to be taking place around the same
time chronologically in universe that
spider-man no way home will take place
and also in the city of new york that
means that any city-wide events that go
down and no way home should affect the
world of hawkeye and vice versa and we
just cannot ignore that both avengers
here are being motivated by publicity
scandals on top of all the clues i
mentioned hawkeye including the kingpin
associated characters of echo in the
tracksuit draculas and that footage
auction supply hawkeye looks like the
first mcu title to truly explore
manhattan's criminal underworld at least
without the influence of avenger level
technology and if you consider that
spider-man far from home removed that
whole sequence where spider-man fought
the man freddie crime family i mean this
show looks completely iron man free at
least beyond the footlights of broadway
and famously in the marvel world
everything below the skyline in new york
is supposed to be kingpin's turf now in
no way home a total of five famous
spider-man villains have been confirmed
doc ock green goblin sandman electro in
the lizard a number of rumors have said
that there will be a sixth villain that
marvel is currently keeping under wraps
i think all that is missing from this
villain lineup is a local with the
smarts to rally them to a cause of
ruining the life of the friendly
neighborhood pest who keeps costing him
business someone like wilson fisk so for
hawkeye we gotta be on the lookout for
any signs that new york's organized
crime answers to someone up top because
if so and if marvel lets vincent
d'onofrio reprise this role folks it's
just a matter of time for defense
attorney matt murdock charlie cox to
come to the defense of honorable
vigilantes like peter parker and clint
barton i just think he will be a
different set of arms than those in the
trailer and probably not the devil of
hell's kitchen that that devil and
disguise poster was referring to you all
know who i think that's about so all
aboard the next theory train i worship
at the altar of mephisto i bled into the
kang gang now long live the kingpin
support new rockstars by checking out
our merch options at norocstarsmirch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter at ea
boss follow subscribe to new rockstars
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you